what we're going to do in this video is
think about the significant empires that
formed shortly before the European
colonization of the Americas in
particular we're going to focus on the
Inka Empire and other videos we have
talked about the Aztecs but what's
interesting is this period of time in
the 15th and early 16th centuries when
these empires form but then shortly
thereafter about a hundred years after
they form they are conquered by the
Spanish conquistadors so let's focus on
the Inka Empire but keep it in
comparison to some of the other
significant Empires and civilizations we
know about so as we enter into the 15th
century we have the kingdom of Cusco
what we now call the Inka Empire did not
exist yet the ninth ruler of the kingdom
of Cusco a gentleman by the name of
patch akuti he decides to go on a fairly
aggressive effort of expansion and it is
patch akuti that takes the Incas from
the kingdom of Cusco and creates an
empire now as I mentioned they did not
call themselves the Incas Inca was
actually their word for rulers so this
was patch akuti Inca their name for the
empire that get started by patch akuti
was to one day sue you and what it's
really referring to is the four regions
and you can see the four regions here
that were conquered with Cusco at the
center now one of the interesting things
is that right around the same time we
talk about it in another video you have
the Aztec empire forming the Aztec
civilization exists well before that as
does the pre inca empire civilizations
but in the 15th centuries also when you
have the Aztec empire form the Mayan
civilization by this point is in its
post Classical period its Classical
period is in bold right over here but
there are still many independent Mayan
city states in the Yucatan Peninsula but
the two notable empires here are the
Aztecs and the Incas which form in the
15th century
what makes of an empire is that you have
one group in the case of the Incas the
kingdom of Cusco conquering other
peoples and taking tribute from them now
what was interesting about the Incas is
that they were able to form this large
Empire the largest empire in the
Americas at the time of the European
conquest this Empire had 10 million
people in it and what's amazing is is
that you have this large powerful Empire
with significant building projects this
is a picture of Machu Picchu historians
believe that it was built as an estate
for pot jacuzzi so they were able to do
the sophisticated construction despite
not having a written system as we know
it they had a system of not for some
forms of record-keeping but despite that
they were able to have a sophisticated
society their way of taxing people was
not through formal coinage they didn't
have a monetary system as we know it
members of their society had to dedicate
a proportion of their labor to the
Empire to the Emperor
and this might seem different than what
we do but if you think about it if my
income is taxed at 30% or 35% in say the
US essentially what I'm giving to the
government is 35% of the work of my
labor I'm just doing it for a monetary
system they did it directly a certain
percentage of my labor would directly
have to be for the Empire and that's how
things like Machu Picchu actually got
built this was called the myth a system
well like the case with the Aztec empire
the Inca Empire lasts for about a
hundred years until the conquistadors
come into the picture and Francisco
Pizarro in particular on his third
expedition is able to conquer this
powerful Inca Empire and he does this
with only several hundred men but they
were far better armed than the Incas but
many historians believe it was also
complacency on the part of the Inca
ruler at the time
he didn't believe that these
conquistadors would be able to overtake
his army that numbered in the tens of
thousands